this part here needs to be I'm
constantly checking the time
sometimes for no real reason at all
and I think it's because I usually feel
like I don't have enough time and I
guess this is my attempt to control it
but this little habit has turned me into
someone that I don't really like
so when I started working with my first
client who basically gave me unlimited
design freedom I knew I wanted to
explore this idea of time
and is there any way to slow it down
[Music]
this video is sponsored by SketchUp and
more folio
feeling of being brushed it's a
universal feeling especially in the
digital age but if you think about it
it's actually kind of ironic
all of these tools are designed to
increase efficiency so that we can have
more time and improve the quality of our
lives but instead we're all just pushing
for more more productivity more
experiences more excitement more things
to see more things to do Beaumont but
leisure in itself has become a
multi-million dollar industry that tries
to keep us constantly entertained
constantly wanting more and again making
us feel like we don't have enough time
[Music]
there's a few moments in my life where I
felt the sensation of being unplugged
from the world there's a quality about
these moments that makes me want to slow
down my Pace willing myself to be lost
and to be alone so when I started
designing the Orinda house I tried to
let these memories guide the design in
some ways I think this is kind of the
perfect site you come here to disconnect
from the rest of the world at the same
time the site does come with a few
challenges it feels a little bit steeper
than I thought it was going to be
[Music]
so as you can see the hill is extremely
steep it's got almost a 30 degree slope
so the hours of daylight is actually
quite limited because it's blocked by
this hill
fact when we did a proper son starting
the only part of the site that got lots
of daylight throughout the day is at the
top of the hill right here there's also
like a million protected trees on the
site basically anything over a six inch
diameter is a protected tree so I have
to pick a spot that would require the
least amount of tree cutting we also
have this 25 foot height limit so the
lower we go down the site the shallower
we have to make the floor plate
otherwise we have to quarant to the hill
which based on our Geotech report it
will be possible but it will be a
challenge because the Bedrock is very
hard so this flat portion right here
seems like the ideal location for the
building you get tons of daylight
there's not a ton of trees around and
with our concept of maximizing time this
location seemed like a no-brainer
but the problem was how do we get all
the way up here
how do we get materials up here building
a driveway will be very expensive and
we'd have to cut down a lot of trees and
the City of verinda would not be happy
the solution actually came from an
acquaintance apparently these little
Hillside lifts are quite common in
California because there's so many steep
sites like this so the driveway and the
garage
they can stay right here I bottom of the
hill and so you park your car right here
and you take your little Hillside
elevator
and that's how you get to the house as
you slowly move up the lift you sit you
look at the trees and you can also see
glimpses of the building when you
finally reach the top all you have is a
platform and a massive concrete wall on
the side and when you touch the wall
you're totally surprised to find that
it's warm and soft
in the summer of 2016 we traveled across
Europe to look at architecture at the
last leg of our trip we made our way to
this little Swiss Village called
hedenstein to visit the home and Studio
of Peter zumdor who happens to be one of
my favorite architects
nobody was there so technically I guess
we weren't actually visiting but
regardless the building was designed by
Peter zumthor himself so I took like a
million pictures I peeked Through the
Windows and I touched everything
it was just before we were about to
leave as I was trying to get my last few
pictures I found a nice little window
recessed into a perfectly formed
concrete but something was different
when I touched it I was shocked the
concrete was soft and warm this hard
material had the texture of fabric I
think the concrete must have been formed
using fabric as a formwork and it
conducted heat from the sunlight the
only proof that I have of this is this
photo
which doesn't even come close to
capturing this feeling but sometimes
when I touch a soft linen maybe one
that's been sitting out in the sun for a
long time
it reminds me of this moment
the problem is that vision is the
loudest of our senses and so by limiting
our view of the house we start to pay a
little bit more attention to our other
senses you can hear the water in the
distance and when you touch the wall
you're surprised to feel the strange
texture under your fingertips you notice
your movements the variation in the
walls and maybe you start to slow down
Once you turn the corner you enter into
a garden and it's not just any Garden
it's a labyrinth and you have to take
this Meandering path in order to reach
the entrance of the house and I'm sure
over time the family would build in
shortcuts maybe here and here and here
but the main route takes you on a long
journey this very intentional complexity
of the path if creates a sense of
Mystery curiosity each new turn reveals
a new moment a hidden corner
carefully framed view or maybe a really
soft Moss
here getting lost and then found that's
the whole point
that feeling of being blindly led by her
feet
[Music]
labyrinths were actually used for
meditation by priests during the
medieval times they're non-linear and
they can be disorienting but knowing
that they'll eventually get to the end
these long walks were used to reach a
state of contemplation when you reach
the end of the garden you land on a
large stepping stone which marks the end
of the labyrinth and the beginning of
the house
according to you honey plasma images of
water emphasize architectural permanence
and concretize the passing of time the
reflective surface of water hides its
depth and projects a second hidden world
the double World activates our
imagination for The Duality of past and
future
so in order to get this kind of effect
the water needs to be getting direct
sunlight the light hits the water
bounces off and the refraction from the
water is projected onto this concrete
wall
foreign
so after iterating through a couple
different options we decided to place
the pools at the top of the site on the
south end
one reflecting pool here and one
accessible pool here
and so we maximize the sunlight and this
refraction of the water becomes a part
of the entry experience so over here you
can take a moment to pause we landscape
this area so that the seating becomes a
part of the hill and instead of Paving
this area with concrete we continued the
stone path so that this entire space
feels like one continuous Garden so when
you enter the house you enter into a
hall with wood slots on one side and a
panelized concrete wall on the other the
patterns on the concrete panels create
Rhythm as you enter the entryway is a
transitional place and it's a place of
movement and it's a place where outside
becomes inside
it's your first few moments into the
house where you leave your keys your
coat where you leave your outside self
behind and you enter your home it's not
a moment but it's a in-between moment
and these are the moments that I usually
get forgotten about these moments make
up only seconds in our days but add it
up they become hours and days and so by
elevating this experience with the light
and texture we can make even these
transitional moments memorable
[Music]
as you descend the stairs through this
narrow transitional space you experience
expansion
for the first time you really see the
beautiful view over the hill
the interconnected spaces of the house
they're a fraction of the water on one
side and for a brief moment you take a
pause
[Music]
this isn't my typical process for
Designing but there was an object that
kept coming to my mind as I was
designing the building a sundial I think
there's something really poetic about it
how the hands stay still while it
quietly witnessed the fleeting hours and
Seasons but compared to a digital clock
it's not dictated by the seconds of
minutes and instead I feel a more
gradual passing of time
foreign
[Music]
I think about the sun's journey across
the sky and it reminds me of our
connection to the universe it makes me
think about my existence
context of this vast space and time
as the sun moves across the sky from
morning to evening I wanted the building
to kind of dance with the changing
angles of the sunlight
tried a bunch of iterations of the roof
because it changed how the light
stretched into the living room and into
the office and into the kitchen maybe
this movement can even guide some of the
activity of the house
[Music]
but there's another moment in the house
where you experience light in a totally
different way
and that will be underneath the pool
right here where we get the refraction
through the water which is a totally
different quality of light this room
actually drove a lot of the
relationships between the spaces in the
house I wanted the refraction to be a
part of the experience of the house so
that the living room and the kitchen can
borrow some of that refraction but
because of the depth of the pool it was
really hard to do that without placing
the relaxation room on a completely
different basement level which is why
each of the spaces stepped down a half
story this creates separate spaces that
still feel interconnected and this works
with the natural Topography of the site
which gradually steps down as we move
towards the east
oh
time is a human-made invention we create
a time as a framework to get organized
and measure progress and make sense of
our lives so maybe architecture can slow
down our perception of time
maybe it can make us pause
maybe it can make us notice the moments
that usually go unnoticed
you know this whole craze about the
Circadian rhythm it's really all about
resetting our systems back to the
Natural State and realigning them to the
movement of the sun I think as
Architects we often design for the hours
and the days in our lives but we often
forget about the seconds and minutes so
how do we make these more granular time
intervals more memorable in our lives I
think those are some of the questions
that we're going to try to answer as we
progress the design we're still in the
schematic design phase so things are
still really conceptual and there's
still a lot of things to figure out and
in fact since making this video the
design has actually changed quite a bit
and because our business is not just
architecture it does take a little bit
longer for us to do things so please be
patient with the project updates
but that's also one of the best parts
for me that we can explore some of these
Concepts a little bit more in depth
if you're interested in some of the
assets that we're using for the visuals
like some of these watercolor people
we'll leave the link in the description
let me know in the comments what do you
think about the project and what other
Concepts do you think we should explore
and with that I'll see you guys in the
next video
[Music]